I've been wanting to make a
video on a couple of terms
that people have really thrown
around for a while now.
And I think it really hits the
core of some of the issues
we're dealing with now with the
credit debacle but it's
kind of at a deeper level.
So the things I want to go over
are the ideas of savings,
consumption, and investment.
And you hear these a lot.
Everyone obviously says, I've
invested in the stock market
or I've invested in a house and
I really want to give you
a framework for how I think
about these ideas.
And frankly, I haven't seen them
depicted this way in any
economics book, although they've
kind of touched on
this, but I think this is really
how you should think
about these things.
So if you save money, and I
think we all know what that
means, that's money that you
didn't spend, there's a couple
of things that you
can do with it.
You can either consume
your money or you
could invest your money.
So, let's just think about a
bunch of different situations
and think about whether those
things are consumption or
investment.
So let's say, I have $100,000
that I'm dealing with.
So let's say, I take
that $100,000
and I build a factory.
And I think that that factory
is going to be able to
produce-- I'll make up some
product-- it'll be able to
produce cars more efficiently
and cheaper than any other car
factory out there.
Well, I think we'd all agree
that this is an investment.
And why is it an investment?
Because I'm taking this $100,000
and I'm putting it to
some use that is creating,
hopefully, more value than my
original $100,000.
In fact, I'm expecting some
type of a return on this
investment.
And I've made a bunch of videos
on what a return on
investment is, and you can
usually quantify it.
If I take a $100,000 and I build
this factory and this
factory spits out $50,000 a
year, it's probably creating
at least $50,000 a year value,
assuming that nothing corrupt
is happening in our system.
In fact, it's normally creating
more than $50,000 a
year of value.
It may be creating a $100,000 a
year of value and $50,000 of
that may be going to the
person who's doing the
production and then the other
half of the value is actually
going to the consumer
of whatever
this factory is making.
And you have to think about
it, because if all of the
value went to the person who
produced the factory then
there's not a huge incentive
for someone to use his
products anymore.
But anyway, that's not the
topic of discussion.
We're just trying to get at
a mental framework on what
consumption is versus
investment.
So I think we all agree that if
I were to build a factory
that this is-- let's say I'll
do everything in green as
investment.
So building a factory
is an investment.
Now let's say that I'm homeless
and I have this $100,000.
And because I'm homeless, I
don't have a place to go and
eat dinner and rest and relax.
Because I don't have that, I
can't get a job and I can't
become a productive
member of society.
So maybe, I'm going to use this
$100,000 to buy a simple
house that meets all
of my needs.
Let's say build a simple house,
and I'll do that in a
neutral color.
This is my other use of this
$100,000, instead of building
a factory, I'm going to
build a simple house.
And this house, it provides
shelter for me and my family,
it allows us that security that
now my kids can go to
school and they can
themselves become
more productive citizens.
I now have an address.
I have a place to take a shower,
that allows me to go
get a job and I can now create
value for society as a whole,
instead of being on the
corner and begging
for money from people.
I would argue that this
is also an investment.
Why is it?
Because I'm taking this
$100,000, that maybe I had or
someone gave to me, and it's
generating a return.
And what is that return?
Well, with a factory,
it's maybe a
little easier to quantify.
But at minimum, it's this work
that I'm able to do because I
now have a house.
Because I have the security,
I have the address.
I have the shelter.
I'm able to relax.
It's that security and it's also
the return that probably
my kids are going to be able to
now contribute to society.
Maybe if they grew up homeless,
they would have
never been able to contribute.
And now that they have a roof
over their head, and are able
to go to school, et cetera, they
are going to be able to
give some economic value
back to society.
It's hard to value, maybe I
didn't have any job before and
now I have a job and
I can contribute
$30,000 a year to society.
Maybe I'm working at
someone's factory.
Maybe I'm providing
some other-- maybe
I'm a farmer now.
Whatever, I'm providing
some source of value.
And maybe my kids-- if they
never got an education, they
would have maybe added $10,000
of value per year to people
and now they can add
$20,000 of value.
So that difference would also be
some of the return on this
investment.
So I also consider this
to be an investment.
Now, my question to you is,
let's say that I already had a
house-- so this is
an investment.
Let's say I already had a house
and my family is happy
and we have everything
we need.
We have food on the table and
my kids go to school and I'm
able to get a job and
all of that exists.
But let's say, I still have
a $100,000 and I use that
$100,000-- I'll do it in
yellow-- to put in some
granite counter tops.
I have some money left over,
let's say, I'm going to add a
bathroom to my house and I will
put the latest hardwood
floors, so that my family
will be impressed.
You can imagine.
And maybe I add 2,000
square feet.
You normally can't get all
that for a $100,000 but I
think you'll bear with me.
So I'm essentially doing some
major home improvements.
So my question to you is-- is
this an investment or is this
consumption?
Now, in our everyday world, with
most people we deal with,
they will call this investment
in my house.
And why are they saying that?
Because they say, by spending
a $100,000 in the house in
this way, that maybe-- if you
watch the Home and Garden
channel, they're doing this
all the time-- that if you
pour this a $100,000 into your
house, that maybe the value of
your house is going to
increase by $150,000.
Or someone else, all of a
sudden, is going to perceive
the value of your house
as being $150,000.
They'll say, well, you got a
$50,000 return on investment.
I'd argue that that
is not investment.
That it's speculation.
You are, essentially, piling
money into this stuff-- and
I'll do this in red,
consumption is red.
What's happening here
truly economically?
When you add granite, or you
add an extra bathroom or
hardwood floors or this extra
2,000 square feet, is it
making anyone who's living in
that house more productive?
Is it making you harder working;
is it making you more
likely to invent the cure for
cancer, or more likely to
invent a way of getting
cheap energy, or
produce more widgets?
No, it's just, if anything,
providing more things for you
to have to take care of, that
you're not going to be able to
focus as much on your work.
Or more energy is going to
have to be extended to
maintain this type of place,
to heat and cool a 2,000
square foot house.
So if anything, by actually
pouring the $100,000 here,
you're actually creating
something that is going to
suck more out of society.
In fact, in no way is this going
to contribute to the
collective wealth of society.
The last two examples I gave
contribute to the collective
wealth society, some of which
you share, and that is your
return on the investment.
But as a whole, this is an
investment into society.
And it's going to make
the pie bigger.
This right here, does not
make the pie bigger.
It might make you a little bit
happier, make your ego feel a
little bit better, let your
pride grow, and your self
righteousness grow, and show
other people that you've
arrived, but it's not
going to increase
the wealth of society.
And when you say that you've
invested, you are really just
saying I've speculated.
What you're saying is-- by
paying this $100,000, you're
going to find, essentially,
a greater fool out there.
They could have done the same
thing, they could have bought
your house, spent $100,000 and
done this, if this is what
would have made them happy.
But what you're saying is,
essentially, that you're going
to find somebody out there who's
willing to pay $150,000
extra for something that should
have only cost $100,000.
And in fact, if anything, if you
use this at all, the value
of this is going to go down.
So you're just somehow assuming
that the granite
counter tops that you choose are
going to be the taste that
someone else would like or that
the hardwood floors are
going to be the taste someone
else would like.
I would actually argue that when
you customize your house
in this way, you are creating
$100,000 of consumption to
your taste.
And I'd be surprised if someone
else, truly, is
willing to pay more than
$100,000 unless they're being,
in some way, irrational or they
can finance this because
it's part of the mortgage.
Anyway, this is, I think, just
the big picture: investment
adds value to society.
A simple house adds
value to society.
Consumption is something where
people might call it an
investment because it's
kind of speculation.
One might find some other guy
willing to emotionally pay
more for something.
But it's money that's burned;
it's not creating more value
for society.
I continue this in
the next video.